known as the pandemic but the nhs
coveted apps job
is to track infections is it working or
is it broken
well let's look at the data the nhs app
sent over 520
000 alerts a week ending the 7th of july
instructing users to isolate because
they had been in close contact with
someone
who had tested positive for coronavirus
it's
the app's job to track infections and so
we should be seeing more contacts
as virus infection numbers increase here
are the cases
for england you can see both the lines
for cases and alerts
rising together if you look closely at a
local level in south
tyneside which is one of the highest
infection rates in england it follows
the same trend a rise in infections
arise in alerts it is keeping pace
with infections tracking infections only
works if people continue to use the app
and this is now the concern this chart
shows the number of check-ins this is
when people go into a venue
and recently they seem to be declining
across england we don't know why this is
is it because people are switching off
the app or is it because people are
being more cautious
and not going out as much in other words
self-isolating
to help us better understand what might
be happening we can look at
mobility data for the uk the numbers are
negative
as it is compared to pre-pandemic levels
recently numbers have remained level
suggesting
people are still visiting venues and
potentially choosing
to use the app less we know the app is
causing
disruption for businesses and employers
but experts
still say test trace and isolate
is crucial for the way out of this
pandemic
test trace and isolate is the best way
of handling
any infectious disease pandemic
and it's absolutely crucial that we
stick to it
and that we make sure all parts of it
work the app
is an important part of that of of the
armory we have in test race nicely
the data suggests the app is doing the
job it was designed to do but the more
disruption it causes
and if more people lose confidence in it
then there is a danger many will switch
it off
that could leave us in a worse position
as then we lose
our ability to reliably monitor
infections